us okay we're gonna so okay so it's
Brennan it's Brennon shop so so we saw
the tweets we saw the tweets what's so
what's good
man uh I mean caught off the little gu I
I don't I figured no one would see it I
don't know man and then it gets picked
up all
over um I I mean at the end of the day I
think he does have a a case to sue well
he's not suing his girlfriend is or
but obviously like if my wife was going
to sue someone I'm GNA be part of it
meaning yeah do it or don't do it I'm
going to support it or I don't I said
that she's gonna dictate her decision
based off that so he's still involved so
when they're like you know he's not
Logan's not suing it's like y but he's
involved he could definitely make this
go away so that's what I mean by saying
he's involved I don't care about any of
that what I care about what I was saying
is it's this YouTuber boxing thing which
I'm all for there's a lane forward and
obviously people are listening do your
thing and it's great and I support it
and I watch it and Logan's a buddy
Jake's a buddy Dylan's a buddy do your
thing but in that same kind of Lane what
we don't want to have happen is people
and Fighters these the young audience
coming into fight and go oh if this guy
crosses this line we can sue them before
the fight that's okay that sets the
standard I don't like that I got it now
if Dylan does this after the fight get
his ass
but your reward is you get to punch this
dude in the face that's what's great
about fighting so let's say you and I
were going to fight each other and you
start making fun of my wife and my kids
like me and you me and you yeah like if
you and I were gonna fight I mean I'm a
little I'm a 260 so that's gonna be
tough for you you are 260 I probably
turn the fight down I don't want those
problems but if you started come for my
wife and kids then you're fighting me
for sure yeah that's my reward dude I
get to punch you in the face that's why
we're doing this we don't like you other
I'm GNA punch you right in the freaking
face so you don't think you don't think
you don't think a line was crossed with
the duration of which he did all the
because I don't know how much you I do I
I do I do think Dylan crossed the line I
think everyone does sue him after the
fact you to sue before the fight is I
just that's what I don't like is doing
it up to the buildup of the fight you
know what I'm saying it dampens the
fight because if you you know it's like
it's like uh signing Chris Brown to do a
a a music for you and then you're pissed
that he's dancing like you signed Dylan
danis ultimate Troll he's trolling to
the full there is true you're mad that
he went too far well dude it's Dylan
danis yeah I mean he had that was his
thing
forever anybody who knows Dylan and I
like Dylan he's always done like he goes
too far that's his thing so you jumped
into that lane knowing this kid does
this and and now you're upset because
your wife is furious your fian is
furious again I don't like that any of
it happening if you're going to sue wait
to after the fight whoop his ass and
then do that I don't like Jake and him
going we're to Garner his wages and he
only make $60,000 like okay so we what's
the agenda here to ruin his life like
that's that's not cool sh sh sha you got
big mic here what's up what's up brother
how you doing man good so so I
think we we were talking earlier about
just how complex this this scenario is
but I think
in in I'm not and I'm not saying this is
right but
strategically it was almost a decision
of like how can I oh you want me to hold
it like how can I level the potentially
maybe how can I level the playing field
a little bit right not only that but I
think M maybe in Nina's mind she's
saying to herself like yo if I the
faster I get this lawsuit out the faster
he's gonna
stop so like it I think I think deep
down dude the the the the scenario is
just so complex and we've been talking
about it for the past like 20 minutes
now that it's just really hard to to put
a one a one sentence answer on it if
that makes sense I don't I don't like
any of it I don't like any of it from
either side I think Logan should say hey
we'll drop the lawsuit if you beat me
put the stakes into the fight get us
interested in the fight because when
they both sign up for this fight the
goal is to get as many eyeballs make as
much money as possible to fight each
other cool add more steak to the fight I
can call call
I'll have my Dr the lawsuit if he can
knock me out I'm in the only the only
thing the only thing I feel that's weird
about that is it then puts the it then
appears to put the ball back in his
court to make a decision on the lawsuit
that's not his lawsuit you know what I'm
saying like I call him right now and I
ask him like yo would you would you what
do you care if you're Logan Paul and the
the number one goal well because no
because because you got to remember he's
not dealing with a podcast co-host right
now that's suing he's dealing with his
life partner right his his fiance his
blood and flesh his soul for the next
you know his lifetime and so like to
make a decision that based on a fight
that's happening in five days that a
million people watch that like he's
going to make as much money as he makes
in [__] a week of selling Prime like
in his eyes he's like dude I'm not gonna
do anything that could jeopardize the
relationship with my
fiance I get it then then yeah it's then
we shouldn't have we shouldn't have made
Dylan danis the opponent well that's
where we met out defin that's I think
where we all n it out that's also yeah
that's my thing then you you you stepped
you you you got the wrong dancing
partner like cuz for Dylan with his
background very different than Logan
right dude talk all the smack youan
about Dylan legit Jiu-Jitsu
practitioner Bel ab's a different level
black belt this dude four four time
world champion Marcelo Garcia doesn't
get more decorated so his background's a
little different Logan and I know they
tried during those sit down the
one-on-one try poking at his Jiu-Jitsu
that doesn't work that's not a good
narrative so for Dylan if you're sitting
down and he's like all right I gotta
sell this thing everybody's talking
about KSI Tommy Fury what can I go after
not WWE that's not GNA work I can't go
after his prime he's crushing it it's
worth a Jillian dollars all right he has
this new fiance that's very famous she's
a public figure and I don't think you
know I don't think he's hacking into a
phone or anything like that I you know I
know there's those rumors out there so
for Dylan he's like I'm going to go this
angle the only issue is it's like yeah
he he went too far like she's an
innocent bystander but also for her for
Nina for her you it's it's like being
it's like being married to Mike Tyson
you're mad that you find out he used to
fight you know what I'm saying it's like
you signed up like a little bit like you
signed up for this that's like Mary and
George Clooney be like I can't believe
you're on the movie sets all the time
yeah dude I get it okay all right cool I
appreciate it yeah but I love Logan love
Jake Mike you're the man Bradley you
know I love you the man all this I I
wish none of this happened it got to it
went too far on both sides yeah well hey
if nothing else we're all excited about
Saturday night bro yeah I'm so hyped man
and that's what I'm saying just just
punch each other in the face then then
and then say if you beat me no lawsuit
dude we're going sizler we're going s
okay thank you thank you bro by fellas
by bro peace